village chief pad appearance at the
perks are inspected the damage of the
last few nights the area around these
villages in the Western type province of
kanchanaburi is regularly beset by wild
elephants the animals eat the crops or
trample them like these banana trees
some farmers here have lost up to
one-fifth of their harvest they come
from back there from the forests Esben
reboot otamatone and then on their
search for food they walk right past her
house tableting tank by now what the
wild elephants scare me some of them are
aggressive I don't want to provoke them
so I stay in the house and keep quiet I
don't dare look I just hear them walk
past the elephants only come at night
the villagers try everything in their
power to keep them away these men are on
watch here every night from six o'clock
in the evening sometimes until the early
morning they're trying to prevent the
elephants from coming into the
communities by scaring them off and
chasing them back into the forest they
show me what they use to deter the
animals when the elephants come the men
often call for serene been on for 20
years his organization has been working
to protect the elephants in this region
but he also helps to drive them away
from the villages he and his men
observed the animals closely and record
their behavior on video the more they
know about them the better the
likelihood humans and elephants can get
along but the conflict between the two
is set to grow the forest area yeah is
reducing by by menus by people they won
their more and so there are the forest
area decrease and this area it used to
be elephant everywhere for now they have
sought refuge
in this teak wood plantation near the
villages here they feel safe from
poachers who often try to capture their
offspring at dusk Serena and his crew
have the best chance to continue their
observations the shy animals must be
close by and indeed they're right behind
the first line of trees probably a
mother and her two calves but this time
they don't come out into the open then
it's time to head back when the Sun sets
it becomes too dangerous out here the
night belongs to the elephants of
kanchanaburi